this video is sponsored by surfshot what
is surfshark
true geordie well i'm glad you asked
it's an app or browser extension that
allows you to place your phone or laptop
anywhere in the world not literally of
course it just tricks the system they
make it think that you can be anywhere
you need to be
so that you can get what you want and i
like that we're living in a dangerous
world right now you know it's important
that you've got security for
your most treasured possessions nudes
right now we're all taking them do you
know what i mean it's locked down what
am i gonna do
send the mirror get them out you know
what i mean we're all doing it password
protection
necessary i'll tell you what we could do
with this six nine the stupid prick
you can't keep anything quiet you know
we're waiting for that moment where
borah says right you can go out see each
other
do whatever you whatever you need but
until then date or encryption you can
surf all the websites you want i know
what yours are looking at nothing will
shock me for your own benefits encrypt
that data using
surf shock one good thing we're all
sitting watching netflix now if you're a
bit bored of uk and netflix which
you know does get that way sometimes you
want to want to test out somewhere else
well you can
now you can be in america they've got
some good series take my word for it get
on there
go to american boom bob's your uncle
enjoy now the good thing is surf shock
i've hooked us up when
a company comes to me i'm not like other
youtubers going oh give me that money
i'll say yeah
give me a lot of money yeah but what
you're gonna do for the little people
who watch me
the fans of me they said okay jody all
right whatever you say we'll give you
85 off for your fans
and three months free or guess what if
they're not happy with work they can get
the money back in the first 30 days i
said all right
you got yourself a deal and i'll be
honest with you i think you'll be worth
going over there check them out you know
what i mean the links in the description
below and all you have to do
is enter the code jody that's
g-e-o-r-d-i-e
jody on one other thing if you're
thinking oh well there's other vpns out
there we could try them is there another
vpn that allows you to use one account
for all your devices
i rest my case that's facts get yourself
on there
jody is the code now enjoy true news
[Music]
[__]
wow are they aviators he's my friend
aren't getting thrown away rose tinted
from now on because
we're feeling positive there's an
outbreak but we're feeling positive
and everyone knows positivity beats
coronavirus unless you test positive for
it and then you're [__] do us a favor
before we start can you subscribe go on
hit it
on well done we should do it the way
that amanda cerny begs for subscribers
on twitch have you seen that the way
that she tried to get people to
subscribe was like a
teacher we're at 187
like i don't know what to tell you you
know it's all well and good you're
coming to the channel
but if you're not subscribing you're
wasting your time on mine you can tell
them many times i've had that
speech welcome back the true news true
geordie george
alba in this we're going to start off
with a couple of musicians
who um snitch on people snitches get
stitches well
to be fair he was the snitch she got the
stitches in her stomach
are you suggesting she did liposuction
oh she's had it is she we'll do six nine
first oh we start with six nine so six
nine went on instagram live uh chat
about his feelings he's very emotional
guy
he got 2 million live people watching
him 2 million he broke the record by 1.5
million you know
he's been accused of snitching he's got
something to say to you lot if there is
a street call
right if there is a street code and
there's something so
so-called as loyalty and everything and
no snitching and all that there is a
street code just to be absolutely clear
and if you break it you're probably
going to get really hurt
you wouldn't know but where was the
loyalty when you were sleeping with my
baby mother where was the loyalty when
you
was caught on the wiretap trying to kill
me what was the loyalty when you tried
to kidnap my mother so who broke it
first
i i get it don't fight fire fire i'm
sorry i don't think you're sorry dude
this isn't very apologetic
i'm pretty bad at apologies this is the
worst than anyone i've ever given i'm
not getting the vibes below you to
[__] that kidnap me
beat the [__] out of me video and
everything i'm supposed to be loyal to
that no you know what you know what it
is yeah i don't want to understand that
damn this kid really was
um he moved their families out of
poverty he
he paid for school for for for all of
the members
i get the point like he's getting
criticized by meek mill
snoop dogg og [__] he's saying
they weren't loyal to him so he's now
not gonna be loyal to them the problem
is bro you got yourself in a situation
where you're trusting
bad dudes who will [__] kill people
you were telling them to kill people you
were giving them 50 grand and saying go
and kill this rapper they're not like
the most trustworthy nice guys so don't
be shocked when you get involved with
this slot
and they [__] turn on you and violate
you and do whatever they want with you
like you can't act surprised then once
you get into this lifestyle then you're
in
the way out isn't snitching the way out
is blood in blood out that's the whole
[__] point of it so you went and
broke the rules now so whether or not
you
feel like they did your like of course
they did you wrong these aren't the type
of guys that you want dating your
daughter they will [__] your baby mama
he's asking us to feel sorry for him i'm
not gonna
and he's trying to justify it by saying
i built these people up i gave them
roofs over their heads and stuff i made
them who they are
with a fake gangster attitude and
everyone pretty much knew that it was an
act but still
you can't talk like that and then as
soon as you end up going
due time stitching on everyone in sight
so he's never going to be classed as a
real gangster ever again you just gotta
let that go
listen i'm a rainbow mexican here kid i
rap
is that all rapping is to him how am i
gonna be loyal to people who are doing
it to me
i'm not about that gangster but listen i
know how to get us out you see now he's
rephrasing it now
i'm not about that gang [__] when he was
on hot 97 and breakfast club and all
them that's my gangster exactly that's
my gangster right changed his tune now
hasn't he yeah two years in prison do
that yeah is he wearing double shark
there
that looks like the shock of finding
nemo could someone tell this shark
fanboy to shut the [__] up
have you seen this new music video yeah
do you want i think we can get over
watching a little bit
i tell a [__] don't dick ride don't
blink ride leave it to the double thick
thousand
sisters yellow one the yellow one that's
his girlfriend this is like
it plus teddy tubbies isn't it that's
what they saw in music videos
trucker the rape trucker your bestie is
a dick sucker
he loves that rainbow looking people
never talk about what 69 does for the
lgbt community he's a huge supporter of
that yeah
credit to him why do people never cut
himself no no i never see them what i
mean
particularly in prison yeah just
especially supportive of it there oh
really yeah
you big hater why does he always like
puppies you've noticed that as well nice
to look at he's an animal rights
activist as well
you see good was the bad window planning
this music video they're all like what
do you want in this six nine and he goes
i want s pop piece of rainbows
are you a fan of six nine's music
because i'm a fan of his music but i
have to be in the mood to like
i think it's good gym music yeah that's
what i was going to say so i'm like a
treadmill or something like that
i'm trying to push myself it's perfect
for that are you dumb stupid
it's hype music yeah it's like energy
little john back in the day it's like
that but or necessary this video feels
like a big [__] you to the people that
said his career would be done have you
seen this but
the one thing i'll give him if you're
gonna be that guy
own it all the way like the whole
world's calling you a rat [__] him
embrace it that's the only way he can
continue
to play the role that he's had of
ultimate troll drop the gangster [__]
and actually just be like yeah [__] it
right i've got to sit back in my chair
because since we recorded the video that
little duff rainbow head [__] decide to
let everyone know where he lives you
know you think yourself what sort of
behavior would you have if you'd grasped
on every
you know murderer you knew i for one
wouldn't still be
knocking around with rainbow hair and uh
taking photographs outside my [__]
house so that the last across the road
from you who's you know
in the age demographic you [__] make
music for happenstance
who is that rainbow head gentle oh it's
only the most famous
[__] rapper in america right now you
broke the instagram live [__] records
for a reason you daft [__]
i'm partly annoyed because i've got to
re-record some of this [__] video
even his cars are rainbow colored by the
way you know
just in case you don't know who's inside
the outside tells the story in itself
to answer the question are you dumb
stupid or dumb
you are your stupid [__] [__] if you
look if you don't get yourself killed by
the end of the year
almost a video from one set of thick
women to a woman who
used to be thick nope she's lost some
weight
now she's looking so adele put a picture
on instagram in which she appears to be
a lot
slimmer by comparison to her all the
dough i mean this is just mendel she
went from
that yeah to that fair play that to that
there's been a lot of debate about this
on the on the internet i feel like the
girls used to relate to
that can just be that girls used to
relate to that and they were like
she's fat but she's still a star whereas
now she looks like she can actually
chase cars she was definitely not
chasing cars there she may have been
singing about it i've just remembered
that chasing cars was by snow patrol not
adele adelson chasing pavements but it
doesn't look like she's just because
we're delivering the pizzas
okay look she was fat as [__] right
let's let's be honest and it's coming
from me right i'm a big guy
i'm working on it though we should all
be encouraged to be a bit healthier yeah
i don't think there's anything wrong
with that i get that you all loved her
you know when she was chubby but she's
still
adele i noticed a lot of people getting
annoyed
about this like some of these women out
here were getting
[__] triggered like how dare you
comment on her way
and it's like it's making you think
about yourself isn't it yeah that's
what this is all about yeah when someone
gets praised for looking great and
healthy and slim
it makes some people feel like oh i
don't feel like i live up to that
you then have to do whatever's right for
you and accept who you
are you can't change the rest of the
[__] world to fit what you are well
the word i kept seeing get thrown around
was fat phobic
people saying that if you're celebrating
adele and saying she looks great that is
disgusting and vile and that you're fat
phobic but it's not as binary as that
it's not like okay i love how she looks
now which means i hate fat people she's
lost weight she's probably a lot
healthier as well why is that a bad
thing to applaud i think people are too
quick to just categorize things these
days it's fat phobic if you would
support adele for losing weight what if
a fat person is scrolling through
twitter and they're seeing your tweets
how would that fat person feel if they
saw that tweet congratulating adele no
one's saying anything about fat people
when she posted this photo she literally
posted it because she thought she looked
good she didn't post that with the
caption looking great now so glad i'm
not a chubby [__] anymore [__] all fat
people
no this is the thing though right it's
changed a little bit but universally
most people find slimmer people more
attractive
than fatter people yeah true and that is
just the way it's been
and the way it's going to be for quite a
long time there are some people who are
grotesquely overweight
and who live in a bubble where they
think that that's okay when something
like this happens
it bursts that bubble and they have a
[__] meltdown well i'm sorry that
reality has come knocking on your
[__] door
and slap you over the [__] head but
guess what it's not good for you
to be obese and generally if you lose
weight and
you're in a bit of battleship and no
one's expecting me a [__] stick
that's not good either
but there are healthy boundaries to stay
within and adele wasn't there
so she's gotten there and she's probably
delayed she's getting a divorce yeah
she's gonna get all the [__]
she can [__] handle now it's not been
easier for her to lose the weight as
well it must have taken
her how do you think she lost all that
weight then do you think she had some
help i think there's been
i think that's
she looks different yeah in the face as
well okay so
we don't let's not forget this woman's a
multi-multi-millionaire who can afford
to have everyone everything knit top and
[__] sock you can't expect to do the
same in your own life but she's slimmer
you know and she's happier if that's
what she wants let her get on with it
ultimately we shouldn't even be talking
about this but you lot have made such a
[__] big deal about it in the media
or in every [__] else we gotta cover
it i mean one thing's undeniable she's
much healthier now trying to lose a bit
of weight
really on the ketogenic diet do you know
why i don't want to be a fat [__]
anymore
my decision now to do with you lot if
people think i look better afterwards
then [__] great and if anyone out
there is going to go oh
well he looked great before no he has
warned do you know why
because i'm a man and no one gives a
[__] about men but when a woman does it
oh my god it's making me feel awkward
because i can't be asked to go for a
[__] job
well deal with it so well done adelphi
and the surgeon involved if there was
one
potentially yeah good work doc i mean
we're all for body positivity on this
channel so
i am all for you know fat girls but if
they want to lose weight it's not to do
with me
exactly love fat women most of them got
huge answers and i'm all for that so
hey guys james charles here have you
seen his latest tweet no i haven't got
these are so
good really well i don't think i have a
choice there you go
wow it's quite a perky bum for a male i
wonder what he said
aside from having it wrecked by some big
dicks just casually posted that
trended on twitter instantly i'm
thinking to myself i mean is this a road
i could go down say
next time i want to drop a video and
guarantee those views have your [__]
i mean my ass is better than that
exactly no problem i've heard that i've
had it confirmed you could potentially
do true news lay on the table naked with
your ass out
i'm not sure you lot would would
probably if you want that for the next
episode if this video gets 20 000 thumbs
ups i think make it 50 really
okay okay 50 000 thumbs up and that's
exactly how brian will present next
week's true news
just to be clear you got no chance but
um 50 000 likes would be nice have you
heard about his
latest reality tv show no instant
influence
similar series starting in wuhan it's
called instant influenza
as you know last year i started the
search to find the next beauty
influencer
literally thousands of you answered the
call and i was blown away
by what i saw
[Music]
one day watching all of those audition
tips you'd want to jump off a cliff
yeah so whoever did that the production
team they're the true heroes they
deserve appearance they deserve a clap
on thursday at 8 30 p.m
over the next month i'll test their
artistry camera presence
and potential to be a beauty superstar
i like james i love you i don't know why
i like him he's super charismatic
he's got star quality definitely yeah
yeah fairfax there'll be a few special
guests
you guys are hot too she's got star
quality paracel were you a fan of
paracel in back in the day
you know she isn't my type after all the
jokes i made about adele she is uh
slimmer than what i was she's quite very
slim yeah very simple but she can suck a
good dick
how do you know that watch the video
this video one night in paris have you
ever heard of it
no you that's what we're here for we're
educating this
my name is christian perez i'm 18 years
old 18 years old 18 years old i wish we
did more of that we used our hands to
punctuate when we talked
welcome back to true news guys and now
for food reviewer i moved to la because
after my dad got deported i knew that
los
angeles was the place i needed to be to
get further in my career sorry what his
dad got deported why would his dad get
deported well brian if some people are
living in countries illegally they get
deported just ask my dad oh my gosh i'm
so excited to have you guys here today
i need to see your beautiful faces
though lights
oh my yeah it looks like a transformer
my name is optimus prime i need you to
come on the first day of filming
with a makeup look on that tells us who
you are
as an artist what would you dress us do
all my art artist is editing for you in
it so i'd have to draw you on one side
lawrence on the other side i would just
come as like a lion a lion yeah i feel
like an
animalistic man my needs are very simple
hi gabriel
tell me about your luck today what
message do you get from that geo
um skull earth death to the world maybe
he's a terrorist
so i did the earth and the skull to
represent
how we need to like do as much as we can
to save the animals and
the nature that we have before you know
it's too late your story about mother
nature is beautiful but it has nothing
to do with you as a person
i wanted to see your personal journey
and how that connects to you more as an
artist
it means he's a weird earth loving [__]
to me i don't think you're reading it
right i love how they cut to the
transformer after that like oh [__] you
know i'm a transformer
oh my god whoa tell me about this look
at how it defines you as an artist
i was homeless for quite some time in
2019. i want to know how this connects
to homelessness
if he wanted to do what homeless does
he'd at least have a [__] sleeping
background
exactly he's a homeless person that's
been skinned alive brian you're not
getting the message here
i want at least a packet of tubs a
sleeping bag and a beard at the very
least exactly this makeup book is so
abstract i am really pumped to learn
more about this
[__] hell she was the homeless one
she actually looks like an ink plot is
that what this is supposed to be do you
think this is inkblot inspired
my message has uh to do with mental
health this is actually quite like
it's quite interesting yeah yeah i want
to hate this but like using implant to
describe mental health that's smart
though
interpretation so however it does remind
me
a little bit when you wake up with a
girl who um has been
mortal drunk the night before and she's
like our eyelashes and all that black
[__] in her eyelashes have gone
everywhere
yeah and you're like and she's been
crying yeah yeah skull [__]
or maybe she just rushed this maybe she
just woke up she was like oh [__]
i've got an hour to go yeah and then she
was just trying to do something fast i'd
cry in and she was like this'll do i'll
just say some [__] about mental health
it's john fury dads to tyson fury
someone's been winding him up for quite
some time saying we want to have a
boxing match and whatever and johnny in
having it he's like i'm not getting in a
ring
dancing on my shoulder i want it
backyard bare knuckle any day
any time let me tell you this watch mate
you're wrapping it
bare knuckle all in noah old bad
i want you to go today shout to mullet
pig
are you listening to me pig he's very
angry in it captain mullet pig i listen
to me pig this is the thing right
john fury sells a fight better than
any pro boxer in the game today honestly
he could talk [__] better than any of
them i've never seen john fury fight
i don't care but you believe it in my
head i'm thinking this guy might be next
heavyweight champion of the world
if eddie hearn told me this fella was
fighting
the shapton mullet pig whatever he's
called his official name in a bare
knuckle
it's 20 quid pay-per-view on sky next
week i'll go i [__] it i'll buy it so
get plenty of steroids and juice down
your mate
because i will fight you tomorrow today
anytime me address
51 muslin style winslow cheshire
there's three hours in room slope
everybody knows who i am it's a 10 acre
field at the back
he does not give a [__] i tell you what
right when someone drops their address
on a video and says meet me at my
[__] house he's not [__] here he's
scared of [__]
he when i first seen this i was like
what if someone tries to burgle john
fury and i thought
no one's gonna try that no [__] way
for some reason
no one's doing that he will come out
with a [__] double barrel shotgun and
blow your [__] head off right
he's not a man to be [__] around with
he's a fighting man clearly i'm gonna
break your face inmate
and if you don't show up i'm at every
boxing match in london every warring
event i'm gonna be there
and i'm gonna be looking for you and you
see that i'm gonna shatter your [__]
draw with it
and i don't even [__] swear he
started swearing he started swearing for
this guy i swear definitely sort of
swearing
yeah this shapton mallet pigs really
touched the nerve when he says i'm gonna
shatter your
[__] jewelry he's not even talking to
me and i'm scared
i'm gonna google where this location is
and try and be as far away as [__]
possible
he talks this [__] better than any of
these pro boxers
we've only watched two minutes of this
better than both ksi logan build-ups
and you did most of the work on those no
boxing matches no gloves because i will
inflict some serious damage on you
you'll never do it again my friend
you push one button too far so either to
you i've got
of my top ten of people that i don't
want to piss off i think john fury's
just gone to number one i think he's
more intimidating
in the way he gives it than conor
mcgregor tyson fury any other the
violence
in his spirit it pours out doesn't it
he's the human embodiment of a starving
pit bull
you can see how he has produced a world
champion oh definitely yeah in fact a
world champion
came out of these balls that's what come
out of these balls you've got to say
though
if this pig fell out turns up this
chapter mallet pig you've got to call it
correct
i worry for him because something tells
me if john's got you hurt and as angry
as he is he's going to keep going until
you are on the [__] deck if i was
this chapter mallet pig i'd make a logan
paul style apology i've made a serious
and continuous lapse in judgment i do
not expect to be forgiven
i'm simply here to apologize to big john
fury i am a cheps and melee pig and i
promise to never offend you or your
family ever again have you heard what he
says about mike tyson yeah he's called
out mike tyson he didn't call him out as
much as i think he was like if i'm going
to fight someone i'd rather fight a
proper fighting man mike tyson
it's worth doing charity with because a
proper king of a champion
is a proper man tried and tested not
some not some doorman but i used to
practice him as a 14 year old boy
and if i never knocked four or five a
night at a 15 year old disappointed
and if i didn't knock four or five a
night i'd be disappointed and the way to
use his practice
he used to practice on dormancy so have
you seen mike tyson's footage
yeah most of us have yeah that's just i
could roll a clip
he has been offered reportedly 20
million dollars to fight bare knuckle
with shannon the cannon bridge
let's go let's go champion i'm kind of
worried because
if this was prime versus prime i've got
no doubt who would win this how tall is
mike tyson how big is he he's about five
eleven five ten something like that
that's the next to shannon he's a big
user he is like my size shannon
huge now it's a bit of a mismatch
because shannon's in decent shape mike
has been smoking weed for the last 10
years you worry about mike you know
he looked amazing on pads doing hard
work and and having the
technical capabilities it's different to
actually taking punches off channel
briggs that's a different thing
pods don't hit back shannon briggs is a
brutal man
retired for that long as well shannon
shannon's been out for a couple of three
or four year whatever it is i mean
neither of them are in their prime but i
feel like shannon's closer than mike
is so if that happens you know we'll all
be [__] watching oh definitely it's
mike tyson and it's bare knuckles as
well man i mean it doesn't get
[__] more brutal than that so from
one dangerous man to another conspiracy
legend david ike
has lost his youtube channel on this
facebook page really that's been deleted
why's that this might shock you
all but david ike doesn't believe the
official government story
on covert 19 and 5g there's a bit of a
link there i
i don't know there's so many hours and
there's just not enough in the day for
me time is money i love dave he's a
lovely bloke
and it is sad because i just enjoy what
he's got to say even if it's bollocks
yeah
even if you think it's rubbish i find
conspiracy theories entertaining and
he's not causing any harm no
he's not i mean the way they're
marketing it uh doesn't help
people are putting his stuff out there
as if he's robert langdon in the da
vinci code and it's like well
robert landon finding dead bodies in the
vatican david ike just having to cut our
own london reel chatting i don't
remember robert london doing any live
streams i think it's the way they're
putting him out there it's making him
seem a lot more dangerous
than a little old man you know he's
hands on he can't even make a fist he's
not going to punch you he's like a
little t-rex
he's not john fury no right they're
treating him almost like the che guevara
of conspiracy theorists
he's just having a little chat he's
harmless in london real i've marked
him like this is siaz mcgregor three
like a ufc they're calling it
rose ike three what does rose mean rose
is the fella who was interviewed i think
he's inserting his name in there just to
make sure everyone knows
i'm here too nothing against brian rose
he's a lovely guy but people are there
for david ike you know they want to hear
how much mad [__] he's going to come out
with wait is it because they're like
debating each other or something
did you just sit there i've interviewed
david before and it really isn't much of
a conversation with him you just
you hit the button moon landing princess
diana go video he just goes
he's like buzz lightyear to conspiracy
and beyond yeah they called it rose ike
three
i'm uncomfortable with that you know
what i mean it's like yeah you're not
going to see rosace 3 at madison square
gardens are you
this summer at madison square garden the
conspiracy debate you've all been
waiting for
rose versus ike 3 brought to you by
matchroom conspiracy hello
let's get a running conspiracy
oh that's what they wanted yeah you feel
free to use that they market it like
it's like a clash of the titans it's
like it's just two old dudes having a
cup are talking about conspiracies yeah
like it's not that deep
the problem is david's been telling
everyone for years they're all in it
mind they're all together
they're all together and then facebook
and youtube both delete them at the same
time on the same day they're not the
same company they're not
linked in any way so he's sitting there
going i told you so
you told yourself the problem is it's
kind of improving right in that way
to an extent unless youtube and facebook
are on the phone with each other like
yeah we'll do it at the same time you
ready for the ready ready deleted there
you go he gets up the next morning uh
right let's just how many subscribers am
i on today oh
uh logan paul vlogs looking forward to
oh [__] hell they've deleted it
it's almost on a million subscribers so
there's one theory that says this is a
tonic cult ruling the earth and that
they've had
david ike's channel deleted because he's
speaking the truth
and they're frightened and then there's
another one that goes sort of
uh ruining the advertising money for
gotta get rid of you which is probably
the most likely thing bit of both maybe
you know that's why i usually go down
the line i do feel sorry from because he
has got some stuff right everybody's
wanking themselves off because [__]
david ike and brian rosa
having a chat that's all they're doing
two [__] men
sat on chairs telling you how [__] the
[__] world is
oh laughs finished and that's it and
what else are they doing
they're making a [__] fortune i think
london really making a fortune i don't
think david likes
any of them david let's get
the same cardigan for 20 years david
alex turned up to brian rose going how
much we made this week brian and he said
you're in luck david we got
40 pounds yeah there's your hair is that
once you get that rolex and he's like
doesn't matter david brian rose is
[__] going donations over 750 [__]
grams
over a million now 1.2 million or
something they set up
a platform to put their videos out on um
because youtube
had shutting them down they got over a
million on the back of the david like
streams all they're doing is [__]
conning you
and [__] not so much ag without
[__] brian rose
just wanking himself off oh i've got
david agg and my channel
this guy is such a [__] character do
you think that brian rose is overusing
david ike let's have a look look at the
channel all right david ike
david ike david ike david david david
david ike wait and this just in the past
month yeah this is like the last month
i'm worried about david ike today
probably don't want the 60 odd year old
bloke coming to london then to do yeah
bit risky in london right now for old
people
you might have a point the overall point
is the guys put a lot of damage like
videos
david actor him is like a big golden
goose that's laying golden conspiracy
eggs i think the only people come
keeping up with this amount of david
coverage are the fan pages considering
it's not london ike
it's a lot but yes it was the time
for rose ike three
this was the third interview between
brian rose
from london real and the infamous
notorious conor mcgregor rose eight one
achieved a massive audience on youtube
rozak
two followed and was banned
after which time brian rose and the
london real army
i'm willing to bet that not one of the
london real army ever served
in the military no navy seals and the
london real army developed
a new digital platform to stream free i
think david ike
should be free to say what he wants to
say
it's over because i kind of agree what
you're saying freedom of speech is great
but also
you can still see whatever he wants
youtube are just saying just don't do it
over here yeah people think that
youtube's the only place to have a voice
it's not banned on twitter
exactly david actually got on tick tock
there's no big conspiracy theories on
tick tock he could be the first
exactly i'd love a good david like dance
doing the old everything
there is the queen is a lizard 911 was
an inside job i'm not the only one
to make the observation that brian rose
he's cashing in
on this thing there's another person
saying he's cashing in on it so people
are
kind of aware of what's going on here
but maybe brian ross is getting the
harsh right here because
if this freedom platform that he's got
all this money for is built and it is
amazing and it does help all the other
people who've been banned and been
removed have a voice
that could be awesome yeah that could be
great or you could just pop it off of it
and say [__] yourself i don't know you
know what i mean i don't know what he's
going to do with the money london
could do whatever the [__] they want
soap and david just just not on youtube
unfortunately i'm going to miss him but
he's not dead and we can still interview
him sometime maybe i don't know i can't
wait for jordy ike too the rematch yeah
the rematch
this time it's personal have you heard
of big ed i think i know who you mean
this little funny looking fella
yeah all right so for those who don't
know there's a guy who's become quite
popular online at the moment called big
ed from a tlc show called 90 day fiance
don't ask me what it's about because i
have no idea but i've seen a lot of
these clips on youtube
and they are something else it's
basically like he's met this woman on
the internet where's she from
the philippines they're a total terrible
match yeah but they're stuck
together and it's fantastic oh my god
how are you how are you are you real oh
my god you're so real
how emotional the mouth thing is it's
like asian women are known for being
really small she's [__] dwarfing him
well he's apparently four foot eleven
and a half
you're so beautiful oh my god this is so
heartwarming that's the exact same face
i make when i'm balls deep with a woman
she's not a bad looking girl but the way
that he's looking at it is like she's
[__] kim kardashian
it's like a christmas dinner yeah you
know what i mean am i what you expected
do you like
uh oh that's the longest [__] pulse
in the history of the earth come on girl
you just gotta lie
i expected yours told me
mortals
i thought if i told you i was the same
height maybe i would have a chance
he's catfished he's lied to her [__]
lion
busted i love the fact that she goes ah
it's all right mate i've got a [__]
so six or one offer
body shaming fat phobic she says big
butt short this is what fat phobia is
it's okay because a woman saying it it's
fine yeah it's fine do
you find me attractive imagine the first
type
of sort of first date do you find me
attractive
like guys a little bit directly and
they're on camera as well come on
imagine if you just turned around and
went no you're ugly as [__]
that's not racist by the way i had
filipino friend once that means it's
okay and say whatever he wants
well you are okay for me what do you
mean i don't want to just be okay for
you i want to be
i want to be your man i'm sorry bro
you're never going to be anything more
than just okay
that's harsh no it's just true though
there's definitely girls out there that
have a thing for big ed or girl guys
with no necks
sort of you know um like the hunchback
of notre dame someone said king penguin
or like a gargoyle you'd see on the side
of a castle
i love you kiss
[Music]
you can say what you're on brian but
there's a natural chemistry there
there's no natural chemistry yeah there
is this is true love this must be a
financial thing do you think he's got
money and she's after there
he must be able to sugar daddy nah well
actually yeah he was sending loads of
stuff he was sending the gifts and stuff
overseas i rest my case last night we
made love it was awesome can't wait to
do it again
i think she enjoyed it when you say you
think you stink he wasn't sure when you
know you know
yeah you know what i mean man can i have
a kiss no i don't know
it's me ouch really oh yeah
really um give me just a little
there's something about this girl's face
she can't hide her emotions while can
she
she's very very like this is good tv i
can see why people laugh at this this
girl would be [__] at poker last night
when i noticed
that your legs were kind of like mine
they were hairy
what yeah yeah i don't like leg hair
it's gross i love his honesty for a guy
who looks like that would be like point
and finger thought i mean it's an
expression vegas can't be choosers
stones glass houses all of that yeah you
know for those of you who don't know
moth goldbridge is a football
video maker they've been struggling yeah
you know they really have for content
goldbridge
has come up with the goods because he's
done something that we love he's making
some food
well hello there and welcome to cooking
with goldbridge that was so natural yeah
wasn't it i love that
well hello there today we're going to
start off which if i get asked on
twitter it tends to be my favorite dish
it is lasagna a bit basic for a favorite
dish
i know yeah i thought lasagna with a
name like brent de cesar i expected him
to have something more
exotic that's his real name he isn't
actually called mark gorbridge he's an
italian
blooded meal goldbridge in part of the
italian mafia
maybe i'm gonna make going off and you
can't refuse i need you to go over to
the uk
and make some football videos about
manchester united some moves make some
moves for us my boy but look lasagna to
me it's the king
it's the elite and it's always been one
of my favorite dishes and there are
plenty of things that you can do with it
one eat it what the other things throw
it at people you can't bathe in lasagna
what does it mean there's loads of
things you can do with it you've got to
be more specific brent
this is my favorite thing in life it's
called a wooden spoon
um in a previous job in the secret santa
i actually got three wooden spoons
not for cooking reasons because i like
to stir
things up i'm a bit of a pranker i
suppose he's a pranker
it definitely rhymes with what i've
heard people call mock before here's
some flour oil probably two tablespoons
of sunflower oil maybe one actually
and now we're just going to chop the put
the onions in there on a low heat
well that although that to me sounds
like it's on a
a high heat he's contradicting himself
twice so imagine you're there trying to
cook along he said one teaspoon
maybe two maybe two more yeah
what we're basically doing here in a
footballing sense is
we're building from the back the ball's
with the keeper it's with david de gea
how can i bring this back to football my
subscribers won't understand if i don't
compare it to football i've got to bring
back the football and there is the
finished beauty and it's all its glory
just come out the oven like the world
cup it's bubbling
still bubbling i haven't had carbs in
about two weeks just want to grab it out
the screen
oh literally i'd [__] wolf that right
now so fair play
you've got me salivating not for the
first time and now it's time
for the food reviewer food reviewer i do
reviews on the youtube
you never knew such a cool dude i keep
it so fly and do you know why
it's cause i know whether to buy bad
food road trip he's been on a road trip
he's not staying home saving lives is he
i'm not telling people what to do out
here but i'm just surprised
[Music]
you might not know this about me but i
love road trips
day one of this road trip brought us
south on interstate 95 to milford
connecticut
where we picked up connecticut 15 the
merit parkway is it the first time we've
seen him do voice over it feels like the
beginning of a scorsese film yeah
definitely so i was on the highway
yeah people didn't know this about me
but i love road trips
yeah i love road trips girls and drugs
as far back as i can remember i always
wanted to be a food reviewer
[Music]
everyone's doing this now david ike sits
down for a chat he's [__] da vinci go
this guy goes for a burger long distance
it's scorsese if it don't sound like
this i don't want it
kebab sandwiches he's with johnny depp
in paris of the caribbean captain jack
sparrow
i didn't tune in for these two losers i
wanted tyler alone
we started off with mozzarella sticks
for an appetizer just your standard
mozzarella stick
good cheese pull and not too heavy on
the breading the editing's getting
better i'm getting worried it's losing
that sort of like raw amateur feel
like gritty style it's been emotional
but i think
my work here was done for today so that
was this week's fix of true news take to
go outside and enjoy the sun well social
distancing of course
so [__] sick of lockdown let us know
what your favorite bit about lockdown is
i'm the worst bit
in the comments below hit the like
button if you haven't already you've got
to subscribe turn the little bell on as
well that helps yeah press the bell
press the bell
the bell anything will save you before
we go that's everything i think have a
good one
yes do that have a good one